[Music]
good morning everybody it is day number
two and we woke up it was very very very
cold and Isaac yeah yeah I'm warming up
how do you like the experience so far
[Music]
it's my birthday
yay good laughing it's so cute but yeah
I woke up this morning and this paradise
and I still can't wrap my head around it
this morning I woke up at 5:00 a.m. and
as you guys can see from the earlier
footage it was just gorgeous I could not
believe that this is where I am right
now like I still can't wrap my head
around it and had my first breakfast
here at the hotel which is the only
breakfast I actually paid for because
it's very expensive but I'm like hey
it's my birthday I'm gonna treat myself
but I was facetiming Casey and Isaac
earlier they're having a good time
enjoying each other so that's pretty
nice and I'm having a fantastic time
enjoying myself it's been great I love
it so much so for today I don't know
what I plan on doing but maybe get
Justine maybe go to the sister hotel
which is across
the lagoon or maybe I'll get it kayak oh
no it's my birthday I'm gonna treat
myself
[Music]
all right this is a nice very nice get
away from all the today's Black Friday
for one and to get away from all that
until the so the chaos that is Black
Friday this is a really nice nice
alternative got a nice full stream of
water which is rarity in SoCal because
it's always try cold fresh air which is
better than hot fresh air hot air never
feels fresher actually it's the cold
crisp air that feels like really really
refreshing so this is really really nice
don't fall in the water Isaac gonna be
really really cold
I think you're part Incredible Hulk yeah
what can you do I could break rock like
a superhero
I do to that rock all right
[Music]
all right we have made it to our
stopping point as well
there's nowhere else to go unless you
walk into the water
yeah it's press tourism let's do a
little like meditation a little
mindfulness I like the water here nice
anchor point yeah I know how do you what
do you think of this trip so far it's
very fun very fun yeah very
do you like nature yeah nature versus
city summer spring just not right now
I'll eat right now it's like spring
weather early yeah the sun's out now yes
earlier this morning and yesterday was
tonight will will have a different game
plan will actually zip up the sleeping
bags like it's supposed to be done
rather than use it as a blanket
[Music]
I know I didn't mention this yet but
I've been staying at the
Intercontinental and wanna forget so we
crossed the lagoon and we come to the
sister hotel a resort and damn it's way
nicer over here no wonder this is the
more expensive resort I didn't even
think this could get even more beautiful
and I was just coming here I'm like okay
yeah I was proven wrong so pretty it's
gloomy yet you could still see how
bright blue the water is all right so I
booked myself a massage and thanks to
that I have access to their entire spa
facilities dude I had my own private
jacuzzi with that as my view
[Music]
by the way this is not a hot chicken
advantage insane water from the sea
so that the temperature which is very
perfect this is very topical behavior
but it rains for like two minutes and
then it goes away and then they'll be
moments or it's like raining like like a
thunderstorm and family raining and then
I'll be done in like a minute
so it's pretty cool you know what's
interesting being alone has made me want
to vlog more and I think the camera is
kind of making me not feel lonely this
is the first full day I have on the
island so my goal is for the next few
days so just not even touch the camera
today is my birthday so I was checking
my phone a lot and I think for the next
few days a minute right and that would
be so connected to technology something
kind of nice so just be like in my own
little bubble
but I got to completely be in my own
bubble by getting rid of the camera
[Music]
and some fries and a daiquiri passion
fruit daiquiri
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this kid she keeps going further and
further and looks so fun I'm just kind
of nervous about my camera
[Music]
all right so what now we made it to the
bridge the bridge that would cost to get
over here so we're going back going back
for a pee break cuz I gotta pee all this
running water makes me want to pee even
more so hiked and made you hungry hey
you know YouTube robbers for me yep cuz
I've been eating four of everything
no a 3d one of everything and you how
many how many bacon heart hot dogs are
there to this this water I ate one okay
okay so eight three there's gonna be
four for me if you only eat one no good
oh yeah yeah so you're gonna have to be
too funny please okay this thing's gonna
keep growing and you go on a diet after
this camping trip this is it stay
attached it sure if you are say I
haven't been on a very good diet lately
then taken to have been eating a lot of
fatty foods because it's the holiday
season a lot more carbs a lot more
sweets and because of that - I've been
indulging a little more alcohol - lately
I've been really enjoying the gin buck
than making those at home I'm feeling
the effects of eating processed foods
and sugars and carbs and high-fat stuff
and I'm a body start is starting to feel
heavier and I'm less energetic and now
liking it so think this camping trip is
the we're going out with the bang with
all the bratwurst and the hot dogs and
the hamburgers and the chips and the
cookies and the beer Cheers
oh that's so juicy earlier I was real so
hard to like pour anything or use a
table because well one the tables
slanted because the ground is not even
and the fact that every the tables help
was frozen this morning was so cold I
was frozen everything just started
sliding off so much much easier to
handle right now
alright I'm halfway through my vacation
today adventures I could get into today
guess what guys I got myself a tutor
unless it goes lower the island man I
was kind of nervous getting on the bike
cuz I was like oh my gosh
I haven't been on a two-wheeler and
quite some time since I got my
motorcycle license but once I got on I
was like I got this
[Music]
look at me guys I've been writing and oh
my god it cannot wipe the smile off my
face just look at this this is what I'm
writing along with along this entire
road here oh my god I feel so free I
love feeling the wind like up against my
face as I'm writing down at this road
and I'm looking out and I'm just like oh
my god I'm in Bora Bora right now on a
scooter and I'm just I'm loving life to
them this is me living my best life
people this is me living my best life
[Music]
[Music]
the camera did not do this justice
you need to see this in person man this
is the camera makes it look ugly
compared to what it actually looked like
[Music]
okay so I literally turn back around
because I passed it I was like well I
gotta I gotta capture this so way over
there is the st. Regis which is the
resort that made me want to come to Bora
Bora
when I saw Todd in the movie couples
retreat so it's right there
[Music]
all right my time with scooty coming to
an end at least I got to visit Bloody
Mary's which is one of their most famous
restaurants here where a lot of
celebrities go and that's where I just
had lunch man they had this vanilla
sauce oh so good for them mahi-mahi damn
that was a good lunch don't wonder
they're famous but yeah and I have to go
drive back to scooter and they could buy
to the rest of the island there's been
so fun like it's so calm and chill that
there's like barely any any other
vehicles I need to worry about because
majority of them like right now like
like the busier side of the island and
this is busy so that just gives you a
lot of insight and as to like how chill
this entire day was well these last four
hours cuz I have the scooter for four
hours but you
I just added a stop here and I scooty as
I fit my coffee
look at the fishies and it's not a fish
tank
that's pretty crazy good morning guys
it's my third day here last full
complete day staying here tomorrow I
technically have a full day because my
flight isn't until night time but I
won't be having this bungalow after 11
a.m. I think so I'm trying to enjoy it
as much as I can I found it pretty hard
to put like keep the camera down because
there's just so many beautiful moments
and things to see that I'm like oh my
gosh I got to record this I got to keep
this forever in my memories the fact
that I have like this Sun allergy I
haven't been able to fully enjoy the Sun
as much as I would like to so I have
I've been having to be careful and
yesterday with the scooter all day and
like being like the Sun beaming down on
me it's a good toll on my skin so it's
been like a little itchy and like so I
end up getting these rashes if I expose
my skin to the Sun like the parts of my
body that aren't usually exposed for
example my Apple watch
tan I've tried to get rid of it but I
don't know if you could tell but there's
there's a there's a rash now so I bought
this thing yesterday it's the island of
Bora Bora
behind and I actually created a dress
with it last night so I didn't film it
but I did take a photo so Antwan remind
me to give you that photo but like
around 5:00 a.m. ish I woke up and I
looked outside the window and everything
was like teal and purple and pink and
like and I actually said it out loud I
was like whoa that's beautiful
and then I went back to sleep cuz I was
like dang it I tried really hard to like
like get up and like get my camera or
something to capture it but I was just
like wow that's beautiful
okay good night so I realized that the
last clip zoom dickin so all you could
see was my head and like some of my
necks that look like I was naked but no
I'm not and I did show you guys in the
last clip what I'm wearing but this is
what the framing was supposed to look
like I just
[Music]
all right it is morning once again very
cold actually not as cold as it was
yesterday morning yesterday morning was
freeze but uh-huh we've been you for
three days and two nights yeah have you
gone crazy so far yeah yeah yeah and
there's like there's no one else camping
with us there's like no energy here it's
really dead which is like understandably
that's kind of like what you're signing
up for when you go camping you want to
get away from the city from the hustle
and bustle but usually when you go
camping there's like you know faint
noises in the background like that tell
you that oh there's other people over
there you can see them faintly there's
an energy about camping in like this
time around I've never gone camping in a
winter like this before so um yeah seems
like knowing it's not a very popular
thing to do in the wintertime we're the
only ones here we're getting a little
lonely I mean yesterday we did decide
we're gonna bail yeah so we have one
more night but we might bail bail on
this last night just because we want
some human connection you want some
modern day not modern day connection
we're just yeah human connection we miss
her cats right I missed I miss her cats
who want I want some like just
interaction with something someone
something I'm going crazy out here the
wild comfort yeah for the past two days
cleared it out I had fun the last couple
days I think yeah it was a nice escape
from the city I personally like the
isolation and I personally like the
quietness we are now on our way home
and camping trip Wessex was a success
there were a lot of father-son time the
best part of our time together here was
definitely the hikes alright yeah the
hike no there we went down there
yesterday and then this morning we went
down that way
today was the best yesterday was the
best yeah yeah was it raining Oh sunny
oh you didn't like hiking when I was
running I don't liked it yeah it's a
little more like it felt like more of an
adventure it's a little more dangerous
or something I don't know thanks for
checking in on our camping trip we were
headed home back to LA and see you guys
in the next video peace this is my last
final morning here in this beautiful
bungalow I have to say goodbye and I'm
really sad but look at this view this is
the last time the last morning I get to
see this wonderful view at least last
time for now because there will be you
next time
there has to be a next time I need to
come back and it's just it's amazing
here I need to bring Isaac and Casey
because they would love it
so I actually booked myself a snorkeling
tour trip yeah so it's a it's like a
three hour snorkeling trip
throughout the lagoon
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
the most amount of people likes being in
one spot during this entire trip
[Music]